president Trump slams Joe Biden by
setting the world's worst dictator we
examine the EU elections and BuzzFeed
leads immediate alt against
conservatives i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show there is indeed a
lot of news big elections I know people
don't follow this stuff particularly
closely we'll go through it anyway plus
we will get to the presidential race
first people are excited to digitize
their old analog formats with legacy box
for a lot of reasons
save your family films and photos from
degrading are being lost forever if
you're unable to play your recordings
because you don't have your VCR anymore
or your camcorder is broken you can
ensure your family history is preserved
forever you know I'm somebody who
believes that preserving family memories
pretty much the most important gift you
can give somebody and especially with
Father's Day coming up it's an
incredibly important gift that's where
the legacy box comes in you can send
your legacy box filled with old home
movies and pictures they will then do
the rest they professionally digitize
your moments onto a thumb drive digital
download or DVD
they've easy-to-follow instructions
safety barcodes included for every
single item receive all your original
recorded moments back along with
perfectly preserved digital copies I'm
doing this for my parents my parents
have boxes and boxes of old pictures out
in the garage old film out in the garage
and it's just sitting there moldering
instead of it doing that
they could be able to access that with
legacy box legacy box is the world's
largest most trusted digitizer of home
movies and photos all the work is done
by hand right here in the United States
there has never been a better time to
digitally preserve those memories visit
legacy box comm today to get started
plus for a limited time they're offering
my listeners an exclusive discount just
go to legacy box comm slash Ben to get
40% off that first order go to legacy
box comm slash Ben say 40% today get
started preserving your past legacy box
comm slash Ben 40% off okay so over the
weekend there's an interesting article
in The New York Times talking about
president from prospects for re-election
by Steven Rattner Radner was a counselor
to the Treasury secretary in the Obama
administration so suffice it to say he
is not warm toward President Trump
however the piece is labeled president
Trump's formidable 2020 tailwind and he
posits effectively the president Trump
has to be the odds-on favorite going
into 2020 here is what he writes he says
economists have worked hard to develop
models for predicting election outcomes
and according to one of the best of
these it should be quite large one of
the first and perhaps still the best of
these models was created by Raven
a professor at Yale he found that the
growth rates of gross domestic product
and inflation have been the two most
important economic predictors but he
also found that incumbency was also an
important determinants of presidential
election outcomes so how well has this
model worked in the past well in 2008 it
pretty it predicted that Barack Obama
would receive fifty three point one
percent of the popular vote he actually
got fifty three point seven percent in
2012 the model predicted that Obama
would win fifty one point eight percent
and he ended up winning something like
fifty two percent so it was very very
close to the real but when it came to
2016 it was way off president Trump
according to this model should have
received fifty four point one percent of
the votes in actuality he received forty
eight point eight percent of the vote
now here's what Ratner says he says I'm
quite confident that the gap was a
function of the generally unfavorable
rankings on mr. Trump's personal
qualities in other words a more normal
Republican would likely have won the
popular vote by a substantial margin
instead of losing it by three million
votes they say a good part of mr.
Trump's edge in 2016 was the incumbency
factor after eight years of a Democratic
president voters ordinarily want a
Republican since 1952 only one person
has become president following eight
years of a president of the same party
that have been George HW Bush in 1988 in
2020 incumbency is still a tailwind for
Trump because America generally doesn't
like changing horses in the middle of
the stream as I've said many times for
the past 50 years effectively only Jimmy
Carter lost a a second term bid without
a substantial third party candidate like
Ross Perot in the races in 1992 in its
present state the economy will be
extraordinarily helpful to the president
all told Trump's vote sure would
ordinarily be as high as fifty six point
one percent according to this model that
is before factoring in his personality
recent polls show that if the election
were today he would lose to most of the
Democrats by a substantial margin in the
case of Joe Biden by nearly eight
percentage points now the in fair model
is not the only model that would
normally predict a Trump win
Mark Zandi is the chief economist at
Moody's Analytics he's looked at 12
models Trump wins in every single one of
them Donald Luskin of trend macro Linux
has reached the same conclusion in
examining the electoral college so with
that backdrop now we get to look at
President Trump's campaign so the fact
is that if you are president Trump your
best hope here is basically to campaign
on your achievements
a really good record the fact is the
economy has been extraordinarily solid
under President Trump it has continued
to grow at a very very solid rate people
are hiring the unemployment rate is at
record lows not only that but he has
helped to rebuild the military he has
helped to rebuild the federal judiciary
he's helped deregulate there are a lot
of great accomplishments that President
Trump can point to the big challenge for
President Trump is the misperception
that in 2016
he won solely because of his personality
the truth is that in 2016 Donald Trump
won because Hillary Clinton was the most
unlikable Democratic candidate in the
history of the American Republic Hillary
Clinton was so unlikable that Donald
Trump won fewer absolute votes in
Wisconsin than Mitt Romney did Romney
lost the state handily to Barack Obama
Hillary Clinton lost the state of
Wisconsin while Donald Trump won fewer
votes than Mitt Romney did in fact
Democratic turnout in 2016 was less high
than it had been in 2012 by a factor
about a hundred thousand or so that was
not because Trump did such a great job
of depressing turnout for Hillary
Clinton it's because Hillary Clinton did
a great job of depressing turnout for
Hillary Clinton in other words if
Republicans miss read Trump's victory in
2016 as president from created a vast
new movements something no Republican
could have done except for Trump and he
did that on the basis of his pugnacious
personality they could be in for a rude
awakening as they say I don't think that
everything the president Trump does in
terms of fighting back is wrong in fact
when I think that he is a hammer hitting
a nail I will cheer it the problem for
President Trump is that what people want
in a candidate very often is not even
what they want in a president in other
words being pugnacious being rude to
people yelling at people right all of
this may be borderline acceptable in a
presidential race when you're the
president of the United States it's a
lot less becoming because people do have
a picture in their head of what they
think the president is and it looks a
lot more like Morgan Freeman in every
single movie than it does like Peter
Sellers in dr. Strangelove yeah
ranting and raving and shouting and
looking unstable is not the way you win
those suburban soccer moms who are
looking for a safe comfortable feeling
when they get into the voting booth and
that brings us to to president Trump so
president Trump has all of these
inherent advantages unfortunately
President Trump's biggest inherent
disadvantage
is his inability to contain himself
personally and I don't think that this
is any sort of breaking news for a lot
of Republican voters I think there are a
lot of Republican voters who are so in
love with the fact that Trump punches
back that they are willing to overlook
the fact that this actually has some
pretty negative ramifications for his
electoral future and and I understand
freshmen believe me I really get the
frustration with regard to media will
get too bizarre and terrible media
coverage in just a little while here I
fully understand the frustration that so
many Republicans and conservatives have
with the media I am one of those people
and so when President Trump slaps around
the media there is something emotionally
satisfying about it
when President Trump goes after
Democrats the same way that Republicans
feel Democrats have attacked them for
years there's something innately
satisfying there's a lot of shade in
Freud happening here with President
Trump does that mean it's his strongest
strategy for winning over the middle of
the country does that mean it's a
strongest strategy for winning over that
may be slightly right leaning moderate
woman I don't think that it is and
that's why you're seeing Democrats
basically run a 1920 back to normalcy
campaign that's fascinating Joe Biden
has been completely absent from the
public light really completely absent
have you seen a quote from Joe Biden
lately have you seen Joe Biden's say
anything of consequence lately he's
basically just thinking to himself if I
can ride out these primaries if I can
just sit here and shut my face I will
win the primaries and then if I sit here
and shut my face I will win the general
election Joe Biden at least is
tactically knowledgeable enough about
his own flaws to know that he is a gaffe
machine and the more he talks the more
mistakes that he makes and so what he's
been doing instead is he's basically
been going around giving his stump
speech saying nothing particularly
controversial trying to avoid the slings
and arrows that are going to be sent his
way by the media and Democrats Donald
Trump on the other hand embraces the
chaos he kind of likes the cast so
President Trump over the weekend was
traveling abroad I needed a press
conference in which he attacked Joe
Biden and here's what he had to say
about Joe Biden he used kim jeong-hoon
the dictator of North Korea and perhaps
the worst person on planet earth as an
example of somebody who thinks that Joe
Biden is an insufficient leader Kim
jong-un made a statement that Joe Biden
is a low IQ individual he probably is
based on his record
I think I agree with them on that okay
mr. president
if you wish to project stability if you
don't wish to project defensiveness what
you don't really want to do is something
as immoral as citing the world's worst
human being to say that your political
opponent is a stupid human I mean that
is bad stuff and then Trump doubled down
on it so he tweeted out North Korea
fired off some small weapons which
disturbed some of my people and others
but not me I have confidence that
Chairman Kim will keep his promise to me
and also smiled when he called swampman
Joe Biden a low IQ individual and worse
perhaps that sending me a signal so what
what is the signal I'm like I don't even
understand the syntax of the sentence to
begin with he says he has confidence
that chairman Kim will keep his promise
to me that confidence is wildly
misplaced Kim jong-un is not keeping
promises because that's not what the
North Korean regime does they're a slave
state that keeps a million people in
gulags and then he says I smiled when he
called swampman Joe Biden a low IQ
individual and worse perhaps that
sending me a signal what in the what is
that even supposed to mean
so the original version of the sweeted
is worth noting misspelled Joe Biden's
name and calling him a low IQ individual
until to be ID am not a good not a good
thing also when like why are you smiling
along as the as a foreign leader calls
the president calls the president's
chief rival a stupid person why is that
a good thing why honestly I do not
understand this we're not talking about
like a friendly conversation between
allies we're talking about the worst
state on planet earth why Trump would be
citing Kim Jeong RunAs an authority on
Joe Biden's IQ is absolutely beyond me
can you imagine if Barack Obama had said
to the besides pandering to the Iranians
when she actually did can you imagine if
he had said I just met with the mullahs
and the mullahs said that Mitt Romney is
a stupid person and I agree with them
can you imagine it would've been insane
and ridiculous
now here is where the these sort of
here's where the partisanship and the
and the need the shoid and Freud creeps
in Republicans also look at president
Trump's comments they say so the same
Democrats who have basically said that
Trump is as
bad as kim jeong-hoon when he had this
this online spat with kim jeong-hoon
were saying the kim jeong-hoon might be
more sane than president Trump are now
upset the Trump is quoting president the
president Trump is quoting Kim jong-un
to attack Joe Biden and there's
something to that I'll get to that in
just one second first I got to say my
helix sleep mattress is just fantastic
it really is good
my helix sleep mattress is so good that
I cannot wait to get back on it that was
a great weekend and I cannot wait to go
home and sleep again
that's where helix leap comes in they've
got a quiz that take just it takes just
2 minutes to complete they match your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper a hot sleeper with you
like a pleasure from bed with helix
there's no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN has called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on there normally I don't believe CNN
but I've slept on the mattress myself so
I know it's really good just go to helix
sleep comm slash men take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life for
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
a hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash Ben that's helix
sleep comm slash Ben from two hundred
and twenty five dollars off that
mattress order helix sleep calm slash
Ben go check them out right now so again
private we're talking about President
Trump sighting Kim jong-un to attack Joe
Biden and he kept again tweeting about
this stuff over and over again it's it's
just it's not smart but I understand so
I understand it's not just smart it's
immoral okay you don't you don't tweet
out or talk about the wondrous genius of
people who are shooting their relatives
with the anti-aircraft guns to maintain
their own power and that that is really
really dumb and not just dumb immoral
and wrong
I understand Republicans who are looking
around going okay and the Democrats just
spent two years
suggesting that Donald Trump is a
Russians catspaw and that Donald Trump
is a traitor to the United States
so everything's fair in love and war
everything may be fair in love and war
that doesn't mean that it is right in
love and war and more than that when it
comes to president Trump's re-election
prospects just as a matter of strategy I
don't see how this helps press
Trump in any way how does it help that
you have to have Sarah Huckabee Sanders
your press secretary out there in public
having to assess on Meet the Press
whether the president ought to cite Kim
jong-un and his assessment of Joe Biden
the president doesn't need somebody else
to give him an assessment of Joe Biden
he's given his own assessment a number
of times I think you've seen it I'm sure
you've covered it on your program the
president watched him and his
administration with President Obama
failed for eight years he's come in and
two and a half he's cleaned up a lot of
the messes that were left behind we
shouldn't even be in the position that
we're in to have to deal with North
Korea at the level we are if they had
done their job in the first place I
think if anybody needs help with an
assessment its Joe Biden and whether or
not he should be trying to get an
upgrade when he failed to do the job in
the number two slot hey all of that is a
fine case also quoting the world's worst
dictator to criticize Joe Biden is a bad
move and then Trump goes further he is
trying to edge around Biden in order to
I won't say goes further he also goes in
a different direction with his criticism
of Joe Biden it's impossible to go
further once you've quoted the world's
worst man a new political opponent but
then he decides to go after Joe Biden
from the left now this is one of the
things that's interesting about Trump as
a candidate is that Trump is not a
traditional conservative candidate there
are certain areas of his record where he
actually is closer to the left than to
the right one of those areas is Omni is
on the crime reform bill that he put
forward the criminal justice reform that
he put forward that lowered some
sentences made it easier for criminals
to be released I opposed the bill I
think the bill is a bad idea but Trump
is using that bill as a club to wield
against Joe Biden suggesting that Joe
Biden is too harsh on crime obviously
this is Trump's play for minority votes
and he basically says this I mean he
says that openly so this is not me
assuming his motives he says anyone
associated with the 1994 crime bill will
not have a chance of being reelected in
particular african-americans will not be
able to vote for you I on the other hand
was responsible for criminal justice
reform which had tremendous support and
helped fix the bad 1994 bill
super-predator he says was the term
associated with the 1994 crime bill that
sleepy Joe Biden was so heavily involved
in passing that was a dark period in
American history but has sleepy Joe
apologized no so this is an election
gambit by the president is that going to
win over those again soccer moms the
security moms the the married whim
in suburbia is this his pitch gonna be I
let more criminals out of prison and
that was criminal justice reform is that
is that a strong pitch with that
particular crowd so I will say I don't
think that the president is is a friend
to his own strategy on a strategic level
aside from the obvious morality of
citing kim jeong-hoon to attack Joe
Biden I don't want Joe Biden to be
President of the United States I think
Joe Biden stinks but I don't think that
that is an excuse for the President to
the United States to do it he's doing
and you can see how this plays out among
the Democrats so now we move to the
Democratic side of the aisle and what's
pretty incredible is how unavailing a
lot of their attacks on President Trump
are when they attack President Trump on
policy they fail when they attack
President Trump on personality they have
a little bit more to work with and you
can see this from the angle that they
are taking so to take an example beta
O'Rourke has suggested that President
Trump is moving us toward war with him
Ron this is obviously untrue president
Trump does not want war with Iran he's
not interested in war with Iran is bado
he the idea that he is desperate for war
with Iran there is no evidence to
suggest that the fact that that the the
fact that beta O'Rourke is is pushing
that story it's it's a bad strategy and
it's not going to work so here's beta
O'Rourke trying this most Americans
don't believe this because it's
obviously factually false if President
Trump wanted to go to war with Iran he
would be getting a lot more militant a
lot more quickly
here's bado failing to explain why the
white president from some sort of war
monger do you think President Trump was
right to send these 1,500 troops to the
Middle East to counter the Iran Threat
no president Trump is escalating
tensions is provoking yet another war in
the Middle East where we find ourselves
already engaged in war in so many
countries in Iraq in Syria in Yemen not
too far from there in Libya and in
Afghanistan so we don't need another war
need to find a way to work with allies
and partners and in some cases with our
enemies okay so again nobody believes
this tulsi gabbard tried the same thing
she's another flailing Democratic
candidate she also says that Trump is
moving toward war Thurmont now this
stuff is unavailing it's not going to
touch a president Trump in the polls
because most Americans don't believe
this stuff it's obvious that Trump
is not interested in some sort of
massive conflicts with Iran at this
point in fact he's done a better job of
containing Iran's regional ambitions
certainly than the Obama administration
has when Obama left that place was on
fire and when that play went when Obama
left Iran was was on the move in Iraq in
Syria in Lebanon in Yemen they've been
they were funding Hamas and Hezbollah
now they basically been stymied so the
idea that Trump is trying to push to war
with Iran is just not true here's Tulsi
Gabbard trying to make the case and
failing we're unfortunately and very
concerning Lee on the brink of war with
Iran these escalating tensions have
brought us here I'm very familiar with
the region the cost of war and where
this path leads us and the American
people need to understand how
devastating and costly such a war would
be how it would impact almost every part
of our lives ok so again this is a fail
it's a fail so when Democrats are track
Trump on policy attacked Trump on policy
it is a fail and when they stretch
beyond the boundaries of what Trump has
supposedly done it's also a fail so Amy
Klobuchar was trying to claim that
President Trump had been involved in a
misinformation campaign against Nancy
Pelosi by tweeting out a video that was
basically just a montage of Nancy Pelosi
stumbling over her words the media lied
and they claimed that that was a
doctored video
that's not a doctored video that's
called a montage it has been a feature
of every political campaign I can
remember
here's a me clobber char though claiming
that President Trump was engaged in some
sort of nefarious electioneering he was
not and that's why this is a fail I
don't think we would expect the
President of the United States to be
sending out a video that is doctored but
we've seen this it's a concerted effort
there's several videos out there two of
them that I know of Speaker Pelosi
slowing down her words trying to make
her look in some inebriated state it is
unbelievable to me that the president
would be involved in this kind of
disinformation campaign but Trump didn't
do that Trump didn't actually tweet out
that video she's talking about a video
that was tweeted out by other people
including Rudy Giuliani Trump himself
did not tweet out that video and there
was Hillary Clinton who's out there
doing the same thing Trump has been
spreading sexist trash why la blah blah
blah the schoolmarm incrementally is a
very bad strategy as Hillary should have
learned from 2016 but she's not gonna
stop
doing it because she's gonna keep
running that campaign until basically
the end of time president and his
cronies have been running around
spreading a Akhter video of Nancy Pelosi
now it is sexist trash what it is also a
sign that Trump is running scared oh is
that what it is
okay so all of this is not gonna have
any impact now what will have an impact
is character attacks on Trump that
seemed to hit home so for example
Peabody Judge who again I think is just
in pure IQ terms the smartest of the
Democratic candidates in the race right
now Budaj edge attacked Trump over the
Kim jong-un comment and this I think
does carry more weight than what all
these other folks were saying Kim
jong-un is a murderous dictator and the
Vice President Biden served this country
honorably it's just one more example
though of the way that this president
tries to draw attention to himself by
saying things that shocked the
conscience to distract us from this deep
unpopularity and okay so that last part
is the lie right the last part that the
Republican governing agenda is deeply
unpopular is simply not true I haven't
seen a lot of polling data suggesting
that the tax cuts for people who
actually understand what they are is
deeply unpopular a lot of this has been
media misinformation
you know when Budaj edge goes after
Trump on the basis that he is being
immoral that has a little more weight
than when Democrats go after Trump for
tax cuts or go after him for wrong which
is why Trump should stick to tax cuts
and middle-eastern policy and all of the
things his administration has done right
it is a large-scale mistake by the
President of the United States to Bank
on his personality winning him the
presidency when it probably cut against
him in the last election cycle in pretty
heavy ways now with that said Trump is
facing one head win and that is the
headwind of the media which continues to
just be awful at its job as his Trump
said something bad enough that it didn't
need any fabrication a time columnist
actually fabricated a quote from
President Trump about kim jeong-hoon he
actually fabricated this quote and put
it out on Twitter his name is Ian
Bremmer and he writes for a time and he
tweeted out this quote the
was let's see the quote was well first
fur that's his apology but his original
his original quote was something like
the President of the United States had
said that Kim jong-un would make a
better president there it is kim jong
hoon is smarter and would make a better
president than sleepy joe biden and so
Bremer tweeted that out as though that
was real quote just without any sort of
context and it started making the rounds
around the internet he then had to come
out and apologize for doing that because
he failed to provide any context or to
say the thing was a tweet in the first
place and it was not obviously it was
not obviously a joke and the president
Trump does have to run against a
malicious media another example Michael
Wolfe who is a smear merchant who was
featured all over the media for the last
couple of years after his book fire and
fury he reported that Special Counsel
Robert Muller had drawn up a three count
obstruction of justice indictments
against Trump before deciding to shelve
it and then Robert Miller came out and
he just denied it he said this is not
true like bar none it is not true it
doesn't matter the headline had already
made the news so I understand the uphill
battle Trump is facing I understand how
annoying it is to be attacked by the
media for no good reason
with that said not smart okay in a
second we're gonna get to the EU
elections and the ramifications of the
EU elections for kind of global politics
first there's a widely held belief that
procrastination is a bad thing but life
isn't necessarily so black and white
sometimes procrastination can work in
their favor for example if you need life
insurance but you've been putting it off
congratulations you just lucked into
something good you've progressed in ated
long enough for technology to make it
easy for you policy genius is the easy
way to shop for insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape no sales pressure no hidden
fees just financial protection and peace
of mind and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy they can also
help you find the right home insurance
auto insurance disability insurance so
if you need life insurance but you've
been busy doing literally anything else
check out policy genius right now it is
the easy way to compare all the top
insurers and find the best value for you
policy genius com nobody wants to shop
for life insurance and that's why policy
genius has made it easy go check them
out at policy genius com that is policy
genius that can be a responsible human
being
you're an adult this means it's time to
take care of your family it's time to
think just briefly about what happens if
something should happen to you that's
why you need to go check out policy
genius.com right now that's policy
genius.com okay so yesterday I featured
a really fascinating election in the EU
and now there's a basic split in the EU
between people who like the EU and
people who want to end the EU and this
is largely a result of regulatory
capture at the U at the level of
Brussels basically the EU has now
aggregated such enormous power over the
various members of the EU states that a
lot of the populations are looking
around going we didn't elect these
people and people from France are
looking around going we didn't elect
these folks people from Britain looking
around saying we didn't we elected our
people to be in the EU Parliament but we
did not elect this Parliament on a broad
level we never agreed that we were going
to give up our national sovereignty to a
bunch of unelected bureaucrats at the EU
level and so this has led to a serious
split inside the EU Parliament and
you've seen that reflected in brexit in
Britain which has now brought down at
least two prime ministers according to
the Associated Press
Frances Pro EU presidents and the leader
of Italy's euro skeptic far-right
movement jockey for the role of chief
power broker on the continent Monday
after elections to the European
Parliament hollowed out the traditional
political middle the four days of
balloting that drew to a close on Sunday
across the european union's 28 countries
ended the nomination of the main central
right and central left parties in
Parliament and established the anti EU
forces on the right and the
environmentalists on the left as forces
to be reckoned with so everything is
polarizing the censor could not hold
because the centre was based on certain
fundamental lying premises those
premises were that free and open
immigration into the EU was somehow
going to make the EU stronger the idea
that regulation at the EU level was
somehow going to solidify the EU as
opposed to polarizing the EU see what
the founders of America knew when they
drew up the Federalist paper is that
there had to be a there had to be a
balance between the strength of the
federal government and its ability to
fight wars or set national tariffs and
also there had to be internal solidarity
so that you couldn't have tariffs from
state to state but also the states had
to be left with the vast majority of the
power to do their own governing the EU
has failed in that object and one of the
reasons by the way you're seeing in
internal conflict in the United States
right now is because the federal
government has become too powerful
one of the reasons that every local
issue becomes a national issue in the
United States is specifically because
the federal government has its finger in
too many pies because unelected
bureaucrats have their fingers in too
many pies well the same thing has
basically happened at the EU level the
EU is an imitation not of the original
american founding bargain but it's more
like the original it's now more looking
like the American government
unfortunately in the American government
has shifted dramatically away from state
power and toward federal power over the
course of the last century and a half
for some good reasons and also for some
bad reasons the good reasons being
racial issues the bad reasons being
economic usurpation on the part of the
federal government well in Europe
imagine the issues that the United
States has in terms of state loyalty
except multiplied to the extreme at
least people from South Carolina have a
long history of considering themselves
American people from Italy don't
necessarily have a long history of
considering themselves part of the same
body politic as people from France or
people from Germany voters delivered the
highest turnout in twenty years they've
rejected mainstream politics in France
Germany Britain and Italy which is
amazing the results could make the
business of governing Europe even
trickier leaving the Parliament
deadlocked over key issues to come
including immigration a major trade
agreement with the United States at
global warming regulation of the tech
industry and of course brexit the
traditional centrist leaders of Europe
have just lost an enormous number of
seats the EPP the group of the European
People's Party Christian Democrats they
lost 39 seats the group of Progressive
Alliance of socialists and Democrats in
the European Parliament in lost 36 seats
those are both sort of that's a central
right party in a central left party the
group of the lines of liberals and
Democrats for Europe they've gained 38
seats the Greens gained 17 seats it's
fascinating
I mean basically European politics is
being pulled apart in France president
Emmanuel macron party narrowly lost to
the French far-right led by marine lepen
which suggests again that the people of
France may want McCrone as their
president but they don't necessarily
want macarons perspective on
internationalism governing
internationally McCrone his party was
poised to secure 21 seats to 22 for
weapons National Rally in Italy Matias
Alvey knees right-wing League Party won
a third of the country's vote they're
poised to become one of the biggest
parties in the European Parliament
twenty-eight seats in these 751 seat
legislature by midday salvini had
already spoken tulip n as well as
Hungary's hardline anti-immigrant Prime
Minister Viktor Orban and brexit leader
Nigel Farage and was promising to
single-handedly bring together a
contradiction in terms an international
group of nationalists Watts aap coverage
for you know you can in fact have an
international group of nationalists if
they have a shared interest in devolving
power back to the countries at issue he
says we want to be a group that has at
least 100 members and has the ambition
to be at least 150 if everyone can
overcome jealousies sympathies
antipathies to create an alternative you
play you don't do it by turning up your
nose the centre-right European People's
Party in the central left socialists and
Democrats have dominated the Parliament
with a combined majority since direct
elections were first held in 1979 both
parties got swamped environmentalist
parties seeking action on climate change
made strong gains in Germany another
main street in formation the free-market
Alde group backed by McCrone saw its
stake rise to 109 seats from 68 in 2014
the parliament is going to have a tough
time picking a European Commission
president the single largest party is in
fact the brexit party I believe in terms
of how many how many seats are held
certainly in Britain there is no
question that the brexit party has been
incredibly successful the fact that that
50% of EE use more than 400 million
voters cast ballots and that they cast
ballots mainly against that middle
against that sort of internationalist
metal suggests that people are really
fighting back against two particular
issues inside the EU one is that over
regulation from the centre and two is
the immigration policy that has been
pursued by people like Angela Merkel
which has been a giant fail Pope Francis
is getting upset about this
he warned on Monday against the rise of
intolerance and racism as far-right
nationalists and Euroskeptic parties
made historic gains in European
elections he said the signs of meanness
we see around us heightened our fear of
the other the unknown the marginalized
the foreigner it's not just about them
but about all of us and about the
present and future of the human family
said migrants especially those who are
most vulnerable helped us to read the
signs of the times Hey he said it's
interesting since some extent the fear
is legitimate also because the
preparation for this counter is lacking
he said the problem is not that we have
doubts and fears the problem is when
they condition are we
thinking and acting to the point of
making us intolerant closed and perhaps
even without realizing it racist
okay well nobody well now I won't say
nobody I don't think that that the
Euroskeptics are doing this on the basis
of racism I think they are doing this on
the basis of Europe cannot continue to
accept millions of immigrants from
places that do not share any sort of
Western civilized values without any
sort of a similar to process
multiculturalism in Europe has failed
that's not my statement that's a
statement of Angela Merkel of David
Cameron the former Prime Minister of
Great Britain and its failure the
failure of this multicultural ethos in
Europe is creating serious issues in in
large part not just for the not just for
kind of the the historic French but also
for Jews for example in Europe we'll get
to that in just one second first running
a small business it's a lot of work it
takes time it takes money you want all
the time and money you have to go toward
growing your business but what happens
when legal hurdles pop up along the way
LegalZoom is there to help nearly two
million Americans have used LegalZoom to
start their businesses with LLC's and
corporation and more even after your
business is set up LegalZoom can still
help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contract
reviews all of these are part of running
your own business these are precisely
the kinds of costly hurdles that can
take time away from growing your
business
that's why LegalZoom created their
business legal plan get advice for
running your business from vetted
independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states
the best part you won't get charged by
the hour because Legal Zoom is not in
fact a law firm make your time and money
work for you check out legalisms
business legal plan and legalzoom.com
right now get special savings when you
enter been at checkout that's Legal Zoom
where life meets legal Legal Zoom calm
as a lawyer myself I have been using
Legal Zoom for years and it is indeed
great it saves me tons of time and saves
me tons of money if you're looking for
business formation or you're just
looking for business legal advice check
out legalisms business legal plan at
Legal Zoom calm right now get special
savings when you enter been at checkout
okay so we're gonna get to the fallout
from the European elections and where
all of this is coming from in just a
second first you have to go subscribe
over at daily where calm for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily where calm when you do get the
rest of the show live two additional
hours of the show every single day and
we are working hard for you so you can
have all that extra content you need
part of our mailbag when we have a daily
we're backstage as we do indeed have a
backstage at this evening when you have
a deal
we're backstage and you have a piece of
mail you once you send to us we will
only read it if you are a subscriber
$9.99 a month makes that happen for you
Plus this the very greatest in beverage
vessels ahh view it cast your eyes upon
it and be happy that's what it does for
for me anyway it's fantastic go check it
out right now
$99 a year cheaper than the monthly
subscription also when you subscribe it
helps protect us from the vicissitudes
of the of the nasty left which seeks to
target the show on a regular basis when
you become a subscriber you become part
of the team and we always appreciate it
go check us out over there we continue
to grow at incredibly rapid rates we
have a if you're looking for a job daily
we're calm slash careers we are offering
jobs right now as well also make sure
they check us out at YouTube and iTunes
when you do leave us a review it always
helps we have the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
one of the uncomfortable facts here is
that the rise of immigration into Europe
mainly from Muslim countries in the
Middle East many of which do not have
Western values in mind I mean it's hard
to suggest that that folks coming from
Syria are fully in tune with Western
values so that folks coming from Libya
are fully in tune with Western values
without any level of assimilation that's
not that's just not the culture in Libya
in Syria to this point again that's not
a rip on Islam that is just a suggestion
that there are serious cultural
differences between Libya and Syria and
France and those cultural differences
can be felt everywhere in Europe and
that is what is causing this huge
backlash in large part again as I say
not a rip on Islam there was a time when
Islam was perhaps the most
forward-thinking religion from like 700
to 1300 for example when they were
preserving all of the all of the Greek
philosophers but to suggest that Islam
today is producing citizens from Libya
and Syria who are just ready to get on
the on the female rights gay rights
bandwagon in France I think is a bit of
a mistake that is obviously not borne
out by any of the polling data that has
some pretty significant impacts in
Europe one of those impacts is not just
the fracturing of the body politic in
Europe but the targeting of other
minorities Germany's government
commissioner on anti-semitism over the
weekend warned Jews in Germany about the
potential dangers of wearing the kippah
which is what I wear in the face of
rising anti-jewish attacks Felix Klein
he said I cannot advise Jews to wear the
keep eye everywhere all the time in
Germany he said he has changed his mind
on the subject compared to previously he
cited the lifting of inhibitions and the
uncouthness which is on the rise in
society he says the internet and social
media have largely contributed to this
but so have constant attacks against our
culture of remembrance the anti-semitism
in Europe is coming from a couple of
different sources in Germany they try to
attribute the vast majority of it to the
extreme right studies tend to suggest
that it is not nearly all from the
extreme right in Europe that a huge
portion of anti-semitic attacks in
Europe are actually coming from new
Muslim immigrants the the fact that the
extreme rate in Europe which has always
been anti-semitic continues to be
anti-semitic is not a particular shocker
but it is obvious that the Jews in
Europe are feeling the threat which is
why Jews in Europe are
simply leaving even Jews are abandoning
Europe every every few months there's an
article about can Jews continue to live
in Europe it's amazing the New York
Times editorial board disclaims any
responsibility whatsoever for the rise
in anti-semitism in Europe from the left
they say the worrisome trend was
underscored by a report issued by the
German government this month showing
that anti-semitic incidents in Germany
had increased by almost 20 percent in
2018 from the previous year with 69 acts
classified as violence there are 799
reports of anti-semitic attacks or
incidents the most common offence was
the use of the swastika and other
illegal symbols the rest range from
online incitement and insults to arson
assault and murder of the total the
report attributed to 89% of the
incidents to the far-right which by the
way is disgusting right I mean the
far-right in Germany as as with the
white supremacist far-right in the
United States is disgusting and evil
Germany like many other European nations
has seen a resurgence of the
neo-fascists right much of the recent
reporting in Germany on the rise of
anti-semitism has focused on hostility
to Jews among Muslim migrants and here's
where the New York Times goes off the
rails this part is true there are
surveys in Europe and what they suggest
is that by plurality the leading
perpetrators of anti-semitic attacks are
in fact Muslim okay there was a there
was a report last year from the European
Union Agency for fundamental rights they
launched their second survey on
anti-semitism they surveyed some 16,000
500 individuals across 12 member states
this is according to tablet from the
findings found that European
anti-semitism is predominantly Muslim in
origin followed in close second by the
left-wing variety
according to respondents who experienced
some form of anti-semitic harassment in
the past five years 30% of the
perpetrators were Muslim 21 percent were
people espousing a left-wing view only
13 percent expressed a right-wing view
that same survey found that a third of
respondents have considered emigrating
from Europe because they no longer feel
safe there as Jews so the New York Times
obviously is going to focus in on the
German government study that suggests
that all of this violence is coming from
the radical right when in reality a huge
percentage of it is coming from Muslims
and is coming from the far left as well
that is not to discount the evil of the
far-right that is to point out that if
you are a Jew living in Europe and I
know many Jews who are living in Europe
when they talk about the chief threat to
their lives what they are talking about
is generally not the European far-right
just
a statistical basis and anecdotal and
statistical based on that particular
study now what where does the New York
Times go with this this is so telling
where the New York Times goes with this
is they then blame Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu I'm not kidding you
they blame the Prime Minister of Israel
so the newspaper that is that is
complaining about anti-semitism in
Europe is blaming the only Jewish state
for the creation of anti-semitism in
Europe Michael Oren the former Foreign
Minister for Israel he says all the
hypocrisy that fits the New York Times
editorial on rising anti-semitism cites
Benjamin Netanyahu as a source but omits
Ilhan Omar Rashida to leave and
incredibly the New York Times and it's
Nazi cartoon and endless articles
vilifying the one Jewish state and its
supporters laughable if not so tragic
and this is true by the way even the
right-wing anti-semitism in Europe is
being driven in large part by a media
that criticizes Israel endlessly and
then allows the far-right to identify
anti Zionist anti-semitism and
anti-zionism and then allows to cover up
anti-science anti-semitism with
anti-zionism that's why you ended up
with that German Court ruling a couple
of years ago in which to I believe is
true Muslims burned down a shoal they
burned down a synagogue and then claimed
that they were doing a tour of anti
Zionist sentiment not anti-semitic
sentiment and the court ruled with them
the fact that the New York Times is
refusing to acknowledge the source of
anti-semitism is pretty astonishing but
all too telling unfortunately the New
York Times says that anti-semitism in in
in Europe is basically the result of
Donald Trump and Benjamin Netanyahu
which is incredible that is failing to
understand the fracturing forces in
Europe right now one of which is
immigration and failing to understand
those forces means that the fracturing
gets worse so as long as this kind of
sensor coalition in Europe and in the
United States continues to pretend that
open immigration without any sort of of
assimilation or or any sort of of
cultural of cultural movement is going
to is not gonna fracture people they're
gonna keep losing they're gonna keep
losing they're refusing to acknowledge a
reality that is there on the ground okay
meanwhile my weekend was changed for the
worse when BuzzFeed decided they were
going to report on in
stupid stories so here's the incredibly
stupid story the incredibly stupid story
is there is an Indiana piece of human
debris and he is a neo-nazi who is 21
and he went to an Indiana show and then
he defaced a synagogue with Nazi
symbolism now according to BuzzFeed news
this is my fault I am not kidding you
this is what BuzzFeed news suggested yes
if there's one thing that I an Orthodox
Jew who has fought anti-semitism with
every fiber of my being for my entire
life is there one thing that I an
Orthodox Jew who has been the target of
the alt-right and the storm front people
if there's one thing I've known for it
is it is encouraging people to attack
synagogues that that's totally my thing
totally mad so BuzzFeed news originally
tweeted out a man who vandalized a
synagogue with Nazi symbols told federal
agents his road to radicalization
include meeting with the far-right group
identity Europa and reading Ben Shapiro
Breitbart news and the Nazi propaganda
site stormfront okay so they then had to
change their tweet because it turns out
this wasn't true it turns out that he
never actually told federal federal
prosecutors that his Rhodes
radicalization included reading me it
turns out that his lawyers after the
trial tried to claim in mitigating
effect that his wife convinced him to be
a white supremacist and that his wife
had read me and Breitbart news and then
Stormfront so a couple of things to
point out here one if you read me and
you somehow come away with I need to
attack a synagogue I'm gonna suggest
that either you are miss you're
misunderstanding my writings in fairly
dramatic fashion or that you don't
really like my writings very much number
two are we really gonna play this game
and it's not just the it's not just
BuzzFeed if the Washington Post ran a
piece today it is their most read
national piece as a Nazi sympathizer
pled guilty to defacing a synagogue his
lawyer says conservatives helped
radicalize him okay and here is what the
Washington Post reports I'm not gonna
mention this guy's name because I don't
mention the name shooters were
terrorists he has found his way to the
national spotlight since the ruling not
because of discourse over the length of
his sentence but because of a name that
his lawyer mentioned in his sentencing
memo conservative commentator and daily
wire editor-in-chief ben shapiro the
lawyer argued that his radicalization
was heavily in
by what his wife who's 17 at the time of
the crime had been reading online
according to this white supremacist she
began with right-wing yet mainstream
views such as those presented on Fox
News she then moved on to writings by
ben shapiro and articles on Breitbart
news which bridged the gap to the
notorious white supremacist an
anti-semitic propaganda state Stormfront
okay you know what horse crap this you
know what desperate maneuvering that is
by the lawyer to take that at face value
that you read me and then you went
directly to storm fronts hey i'm aware
of the crap storm front pushes storm
front is one of the most evil
publications on the internet and you
know who they have a particular hatred
for the guy in the yarmulke he's got two
thumbs and is giving thumbs up right now
that'd be me okay that that's the person
that's storm from on their top ten list
of people they hate i am on that list
three weeks ago the FBI arrested a white
supremacist for threatening me and my
family yes clearly I'm a white but so
the Washington Post is running with the
story anyway and here's what the
Washington Post says about me to try and
link me to white supremacists attacks on
synagogues Shapiro is a leading
conservative voice among Millennials a
Harvard Law graduate millions of social
media filers let me point out something
real fast right here it is important to
note here that no one in the media
talked about Bernie Sanders being
responsible for the Congressional
baseball shooting because he was not
baseball shooting it turns out that if
you have millions and millions and
millions of followers as thank God we do
if you have five million followers on
Facebook and 2.2 million followers on
Twitter if you have like a million
followers on Instagram and millions of
people who listen to your show every
single day it turns out one of them may
be a nut Wow
breaking news this obviously is
meritorious of print in the Washington
Post but then the Washington Post does
this they actually try to make the
philosophical case that I am somehow the
the logical link between conservatism
and white supremacism they say he has
criticized President Trump but upholds
many of the same views as the
conservatives who support the president
do including outlawing abortion
repealing the Affordable Care Act and
cutting taxes for the wealthy he
previously worked for Breitbart news
this case is not the first time that
Shapiro's name has been cited by those
accused of hate-motivated crimes in the
month before Alexander Bissonnette
attacked a Quebec City mosque in 2017 he
visited Shapiro's Twitter feed 93
according to evidence presented at
Bissonnette sentencing hearing you know
who else's Twitter feed he visited
Tucker Carlson Laura Ingraham CNN he
visited like pretty much every box news
is if the idea is that I tweet a lot and
people follow me on Twitter guilty so
where exactly do they go with this here
is their claim you ready for this here
is their claim that I am responsible for
a for a defacing of a of a shul in
Indiana and the shooting at a mosque in
Quebec last year Shapiro has previously
claimed that the majority of Muslims are
radicalized a false assertion citing
Matt that was later - bunked by pundit
fact a fact-checking publication run by
pointer so this is their key line the
key line is that I did a video that in
which I talk about polling data of
Muslims and this is correct there is a
video that I did in which I explicitly
say this is not an attack on Islam
because I don't try to talk about Islam
I don't try to talk about the
philosophies of Islam in fact I don't
even think that Islam has to be
incompatible with Western values I think
there are a lot of American Muslims who
believe in American values and are also
Muslim I was against the originally
proposed Muslim ban for precisely this
reason in the video that I cut which
cited Pew poll statistics on questions
as to how many Muslims in Afghanistan
supported honor killings how many
Muslims supported the implementation of
Sharia law
those were Pew global poll statistics
that's all that video is you can go
watch it somehow if I cite a poll stat
this is now in a an urge to murder or
done a face of synagogue that's a really
that's how you're getting from here to
there by the way is there any evidence
that these people even watch that video
I mean this is insanity I do love that
the Washington Post cites this
ridiculous PolitiFact fact check on that
video that what the quote unquote
debunked me that that that fact check
from PolitiFact is not even close to
debunk me it does not come close to
debunking that video why because the
video is not to bunk able it's just a
citation of poll statistics here's what
that PolitiFact
rating it they rated that claim that a
majority of Muslims may be radicalized
they rated that claim false why quote
shapiro chose one yardstick other
analysts could with at least as much
justification choose another so in other
words I chose a yardstick they don't
like the artistic I chose namely the
poll data that I chose and so they
other poll data that is not a debunking
and that an even if it were a debunking
which it is not how exactly you link a
claim that there are a lot of
radicalized Muslims on planet earth to a
claim that somebody should go shoot up a
random mosque is insane that's insane
but here's what's really going on here
for the media what's really going on
here for a lot of members of the media
from BuzzFeed to the Washington Post is
they don't like the fact that the show
has become thank God very successful
they don't like the fact that
conservatives overall have a lot of
appeal to people and so what they're
trying to do is label them racist and
bigoted and then they're trying to
suggest that their words are an
incitement to violence when they are
obviously not they've done the same
thing to Jordan Peterson they've done
the same thing to say I'm Harris who's
not even conservative this is vile it's
disgusting
the same people who will defend Ilhan
Omar who is using openly anti-semitic
language or Rasheeda Talib using openly
anti-semitic language will suggest that
if I say Pew global poll statistics that
I am responsible then for the defacing
of a synagogue in Indiana
that's badly motivated crap right there
and it is obviously badly motivated crap
and it's an attempt to silence debate
it's an attempt to quash debate and the
media are engaged in it on a full-scale
level they're ready to do this on a
full-scale level if this is the game
that they want to play where anybody who
does something bad if they cite anyone
anyone without any real connection to
that person's idea that person is guilty
this is gonna become a very ugly
business very quickly because it turns
out that there are a lot there are a lot
of bad people who cite a lot of not bad
people as motivation for their acts this
is pretty disgusting stuff by BuzzFeed
to report on this it's disgusting of the
Washington Post to report on this as
though it is real it's it's pretty
absurd okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so over the
weekend got a chance to watch John wick
3 which I was promoting last week as
though I'd been paid to do it John wick
1 & 2 are pretty terrific John wick 3
has some of the best action scenes in
history is it better than Citizen Kane
I'm not gonna say yes but you might John
wick 3 this here's a little bit of
preview
you have no idea what's coming
mr. wit broke the rules
I trust you understand the repercussions
if he survives John with an ex
communicator is now
you shouldn't be here nice suit good to
see you too so the movie is so it's
purely dumb and purely wonderful it's
got some of the there are a couple of
action scenes that are just terrific
most of them the best action scenes
actually happened near the beginning of
the film there's the the very kind of
already ubiquitous image of counter read
riding a horse through the streets it's
great it's just it's just great so go
check out John wick 3 it's a lot of fun
it is very very bloody obviously it's
got some gasp moments in terms of
treatment of the human body shall we say
but it is it's got some great action
scenes I do like the underground theory
that's going around online right now
about John Luke 3 which is that John
wick 3 is actually the virtual reality
in which the matrix exists so it is the
matrix because Laurence Fishburne is
also in this so it's Laurence Fishburne
and John wick and there's a scene in a
hotel in dim lighting in which Keanu
Reeves takes on an army so I do like
that fan theory okay time for some
things that I hate okay thing that I
hate number one today one thing that I
definitely like is people on the Left
who are fine with anti-semitism suddenly
declaring that they're anti
anti-semitism so AOC is one of these
people the ubiquitous Alexander Ocasio
Cortese brilliance fresh very face she
who has sided with Linda Sarsour and who
has sided with with Ilhan Omar and
Rasheeda Talib and Jeremy Corbyn she's
very upset because there's a political
article and they had a picture of Bernie
Sanders with his three houses and the
headline was Bernie Sanders might still
be cheap but he's sure not poor and then
she tweeted out can political expect us
to can explains who can political
explained to us how photoshopping money
trees next to the only Jewish candidate
for president and talking about how
cheap and Ricci is isn't anti-semitic or
are they just letting this happen
because he's a progressive politician
they don't like yes I'm sure Politico is
just out there to rip on Bernie Sanders
by the way the idea that you can't say
that Bernie Sanders being wealthy as a
story because that's anti-semitic that
no one knows Bernie Sanders is a Jewish
candidate because he's an outspoken
atheist well yeah I'm not
sure honestly like we've now reached the
point where pointing out the Tom Steyer
is rich and donates a lot of money to
politics he's anti-semitic but saying
that Jews are are hypnotizing the world
is not anti-semitic and aoc win forgive
me if I don't take her Prada stations on
anti-semitism particularly seriously hey
time for another thing that I hate so I
don't know why the media do this but
apparently it's a thing for the media to
find some sort of semi famous quasi
famous actor or comedian to talk about
politics and perhaps the dumbest
possible way the latest example of this
comes courtesy of CBS News
so CBS News cut a video with a person in
Busy Philipps who seems to play like the
best friend in a lot of movies and here
is and she cut a video on why the media
needs to pay more attention to periods
not like the not the the punctuation
mark the female bodily function here is
a little bit of this dumb video from CBS
News Monster Crimson Tide strawberry
week there's so many euphemisms for
having a period whether it's your friend
visiting and flow that time of the month
that's just something that we've grown
up with right I've always thought that
it was something embarrassing that I had
to hide I would never talk about I
wouldn't talk about with my friends I
wouldn't talk about it with anyone we
didn't talk about it at all you have to
mask it with other phraseology and that
makes the taboo persist this sends the
wrong message to little girls that they
are not treated equally because they
were born female what no I'm so what I
mean honestly kind of confused so what
is the giant taboo that everyone is
talking about it seems to me that female
hygiene products tampons that the panty
liner like all this stuff is available
very cheap at the local CVS and it seems
to me that people are pretty well aware
of of periods which other bodily
functions do people talk about all the
time in order to violate the stigma what
are we even talking about here like I'm
so confused like it's not
medical problem it's a normal bodily
function uh what's the advocacy for here
what I'm M bewildered I'm bewildered and
every woman that I know who has
daughters has talked to her her
daughter's about this kids are taught
about this in school in sex ed classes
and in biology classes where is the
taboo that I am is there taboo that I'm
not aware of about talking about periods
where people are like you can't talk
about that put them in the stocks where
is this happening this isn't a big piece
at CBS News about why we can't talk
about periods
last I checked CBS News is a pretty big
outlet I like the intense music
underneath if we don't talk about this
bodily function then what exactly it's
just okay
we've reached the point of absurdity
maybe our civilization has reached its
end stage I got nothing for you
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with a couple additional hours or
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know the EU
just held an election and the
establishment the people in charge were
nearly wiped off the face of the earth
everybody's talking about it
but nobody's talking about race gee I
wonder why people are afraid to talk
about race we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin